[Music]
the fact it was delayed by a week
because of the government shutdown told
us a lot about the state of the union
before Donald Trump even opened his
mouth and for the first time he faces a
divided Congress Democrats in control of
the House of Representatives and a new
Speaker Nancy Pelosi watching over the
president's shoulder he started with a
call for unity together we can break
decades of political stalemate we can
bridge all divisions heal old wounds
build new coalition's forge new
solutions and unlock the extraordinary
promise of America's future policies
reactions tell you a lot about the mood
in American politics
and from a president under investigation
this is unlikely to build bridges an
economic miracle is taking place in the
United States and the only thing that
can stop it
our Foolish wars politics or ridiculous
partisan investigations the big divide
is that rule he promised on immigration
he's not backing down in the past most
of the people in this room voted for a
wall but the proper wall never got built
I will get it built
simply put walls work and walls save
lives
and there were familiar strong words on
trade and foreign wars Venezuela and
Iran and Confirmation Hill meet Kim
jong-un at the end of the month he did
get democrat cheers for this we also
have more women serving in Congress then
at any time before
but most of them are elected to stop his
agenda and dressed in white to protest a
president they say ignores women for the
first time the official response came
from an african-american woman even as I
am very disappointed by the president's
approach to our problems I still don't
want him to fail but we need him to tell
the truth and to respect his duties and
respect the extraordinary diversity that
defines America I am asking you to
choose greatness whether Trump's talk of
compromise survives the next tweets is
the question another shutdown looms and
the divisions in America remain clear
for everyone to see Greg Milam Sky News
Washington